[Music]
boom what's up everyone how you doing
welcome to simulation I'm your host Don
sake on really excited to be talking
about the life of running our YouTube
channel
Oh what up what up everyone thank you
for tuning in I really appreciate it it
means a lot to us and it's actually a
tremendous amount of fun to be able to
run a YouTube channel like it's probably
one of the coolest things to be able to
do it and it's also a huge
responsibility because one has to be
able to properly disseminate really
high-quality knowledge and information
to other people so it can't just be
sources of disinformation that is
horrible
and we absolutely do not want any more
of that on our planet we're actually way
way overloaded with that already
there's too much disinformation only the
highest quality knowledge now peep
that's it done highest quality knowledge
so that's what I take on as a
responsibility is to only give the
highest quality knowledge possible so
alright we host the show it's called
simulation a little bit of back on our
background on what we do on YouTube we
host show called simulation we do
long-form nuance driven
multidisciplinary discourse with
different great leaders of our time and
that means everything from AI and
robotics to biotech to neuro tech to
blockchain and cryptocurrency to
geopolitics to emotional intelligence to
spirituality we are all over the place
and we love that it builds a very strong
mental lattice from moving forward so
I'm going to break down the nuance of
what it's like to host this interview
show to do
live events as well to manage the
finances of everything to manage the
social media of everything to actually
be able to retain a first principles
perspective on all of this it's
ridiculously difficult and I have some
notes that I'm going to share with you
as we go through that way you guys
actually have a better sort of visual
representation of what I'm discussing as
well I'm really excited to be able to
look over all of this with you guys and
walk through this because I think it's
extremely needed in our world especially
for Gen Z
kids cuz Gen Z kids are coming in to
with their own YouTube channels right
now and we need them to have a high
amount of not only information that they
carry that they really want to have
strong forms of advancing civilization
maximally but also that they have a
place to go and learn about what it
actually is like running a youtube
channel alright let's jump you guys into
our mixed effects so you can see what I
have here one of the first things that I
want to talk about is this this first
principles idea so it means that
everything that we are building here is
built based on advancing civilization
forward that's our first principle and
we want to do it with as much cohesion
and love and care for each other as
possible and that's what we're building
from first and foremost and you'll see
that throughout everything that we do we
carry that first principles mentality
with us
it was interesting after I delivered the
TEDx San Francisco talk I had several
people approaching me and wanting to
talk to me and I just retained an
extremely humble and some an open and
loving personality as which I do all the
time as much as possible
and it was great that I had some
comments afterward that like whoa like
it's so great that Alan can retain such
humility at this time and I want to try
and help other people really retain that
humility that we know nothing and so
it's really important to retain that
first principles understanding of who
you are what your mission is here and to
be vigilant with your time which we'll
get to in a minute so some of the things
that we care about building our this
Polymathic education platform and that
means that we want to we want to have a
lot of different multidisciplinary
content and we want to be able to have
anyone accessing that content at any
time and learning especially young
people and we want to go forth and do
crazy things like fill sports stadium so
we want to fill sports stadiums we want
to fill
Rena's and i mean thousands of curious
intellectuals for full-day
multidisciplinary events and these
includes things like debates this
includes things like comedy skits this
includes all different types of
meditations so really trying to and
trying to be something that has never
been done before and you know we have a
picture in our studio of the Colosseum
because that's a big inspiration for us
on the filling stadiums and arenas side
of things um also this created these
creative warehouses actualizing the
potential of youth into our world so we
want to make it really easy for young
people to be able to have whatever
resources they need in order to really
be able to find out what they creatively
care about more than everything anything
else so and build that into the world so
that's another one of them and then got
a half of your five second elevator
pitch nailed down so I have now over in
time developed out the elevator pitch I
think it's really important for everyone
that's running a YouTube channel or
business in general to be able to do a
lot of this is actually life of running
YouTube channel but also life running a
business kind of at the same time but
you'll see what the differentiators are
with YouTube channel being a free
thinker having little affiliations
so not affiliating yourself with binary
thinking loving the nuance asking
powerful questions and parsing society
for maximal knowledge and people
networks because you're being vigilant
with your time so you want to know where
can I find the highest signal in the
world of noise and how can I find the
strongest smartest people to surround
myself with as I strive to achieve my
goals so alright for an interview show
or first a good amount of YouTube shows
nowadays there are guests so that means
you have to reach out to people via
email or DM of on whatever platform and
it means that you have to coordinate
with them and their schedule on when it
best works to feature them on your show
and so that actually ends up being a
significant amount of work because
there's a lot of back
and fourth thing there's a lot of
parsing and trying to figure out who the
best possible guests are for your show
so then we just landed in Egypt baby
would these backgrounds have been so lit
I'm so happy that we have a green screen
this is one of the things that I really
highly recommend for youtubers is to be
able to pull forth a green screen so you
can throw up really awesome a
thought-provoking imagery in the
background we love ancient civilizations
and learning from them so all these
different images that you've seen have
been very important to us in one way or
another and having a more strong mental
lattice of reality so booking really
thought-provoking guests also doing show
research obviously when you book that
thought-provoking guest you have to do
research on the guests so that way you
when they come in here you can say
things like oh yeah your book you know
you actually know they wrote a book you
know even better you've at least skimmed
their book you at least have watched a
video on their book a short one whatever
you need to do or even better read their
book but you know get as much knowledge
about who they are in as possible there
is also another side to that coin which
is it's nice being it's nice being fresh
when you talk to someone in terms of not
knowing certain things about them that
way when they say something like that
they may have you know had a significant
injury in their life that ended up
helping them become who they are at a
really high level that you're you're
shocked perspective will be real then
instead of being like that story yes I
just blew my mind when you Tommy that so
there's a difference there as well all
right
and then it's a two-hour show but so I
mean it's an hour-long show but then
there's the you know 30 minutes of the
person coming in and settling and us
getting them what they need as they
settle and then also writing down on the
whiteboard the outline of the points
that we want to hit and so these are
live shows so there's no editing there
but then you have to go onto YouTube
later and Facebook and these platforms
that have video and we stream to two
content delivery networks from a
TriCaster which I'll get to in a moment
that means we that means we have to go
update the bio and update the thumbnail
on the 10
eggs in the playlist and everything
across across two of them and so that
means making the thumbnails and
platforms like sketch or in Photoshop
and getting really good at making
thumbnails and then updating the tags
updating playlists and keeping these
really good you have to have strong tags
you have to have strong playlists and
then this is this becomes a lot of work
actually managing the community on
YouTube managing the community on
Facebook it's just a tremendous amount
of work to actually be able to to go
back and and unlike people's comments
and and ask them you know how can I
become better or thanks for this comment
or ask them a question returned about
how to become better what they wanted to
address that was a thought-provoking
thing you know hit them back with with
another interesting thought and you have
to do that across platform so it's just
a lot of work and then it it's also a
tremendous amount of work having to
manage your postings across the social
accounts because that means your Twitter
your Facebook your your Instagram your
Linkedin your snapchat all these
profiles in here just check just look at
how crazy this is you know here's our
you know you can see here's our YouTube
you know we got 532 vids up now and you
know here's our interviews here's our
long-form interviews here here's that
AMA we just did right and so it's kind
of crazy because you know when when you
end up looking at all this content this
is a lot of videos that have to be
managed to have to have thumbnails made
and tags made and BIOS made and comments
reply to and whatnot and so you know
here's the here's the never ending list
of you know of comments as well that we
have to reply to here's Facebook so on
Facebook you have to do the similar
video manager here that you have to deal
with and so you have to again similarly
go on Facebook here's our you know
Facebook page so we have to manage our
entire Facebook page and constantly post
and engage here which takes a lot of
work and then Oulu crabber Mason what's
up shout out to you what is the
simulation elevator pitch I gave it at
the beginning you can check it out
and then also there's the there's the
Instagram account there's the Twitter
account and I'm taking you through all
of these there's the LinkedIn account
there's you know this is interesting
because a lot of people don't know that
we also do live events and so you know
here I'm going to show you our our
cognition crisis live event that's
coming up on this Friday featuring dr.
Adam gazelle II one of the leading
neuroscientists and so you know so here
you have to you know when you click view
you'll see you know here's a live events
you have to go and update the bio of the
live event you have to go and update the
banner and you have to manage those
ticket sales and have volunteers at the
event and and have a good guest
experience which I'll get to in more
detail in a moment and you have to you
know you have to play in the attention
economy so you have to build
relationships the people you have to
build with people so that they see that
you care about them and that you want
them along your journey and that you're
providing them with a high amount of
value which is what keeps them we have
to capture these stories during the day
if keep your website up today and
stories meaning you have to document
your day and you know Gary Vee says some
interesting stuff he says to document
not create which is really interesting
that he says that so as in it's easier
to do something like document this right
now this life of running a youtube
channel video rather than if i it didn't
take me that long to do pre-production
for this and now I'm just going live
with my notes versus if I was to try and
storyboard out multiple days of me
running around the city showing you all
of this stuff it just takes a long time
to do all that so it's a different to
document to just take that front facing
camera and document yourself on your
like on your story on Instagram or
snapchat Facebook whatever those stories
so all right bouncing back to the list
managing finances this is obviously an
interest in a very interesting thing
that we're really not taught that much
when we're young is actually knowing how
to handle paying your rent paying for
things like business class Internet
covering things like your insurance
buying food instinct frugal
ending up your patreon account and
managing your patreon a council stays up
to date and you keep posting there and
you manage with the patrons so that's a
lot of work upgrading your equipment so
you move from from like we were saying
earlier in the in the AMA that we have
this light here that's not sustainable
it's an old-school light so we need to
get an LED light one of those light
rings so that's one of the upgrades that
we need to get for the studio and like
other things like obviously this we
mentioned an AMA as well but we're
struggling with the YouTube monetization
because we've had over a thousand subs
almost since we basically started the
channel at the beginning of the year but
it's been so difficult applying for
times now for monetization over and over
and over again with YouTube and getting
declined because out of the 535 videos
that we have on our channel apparently
like five of them or so have had a video
embedded in them and it hasn't been
original content but over 99.9% of our
content is original content where were
99% of our content is original content
so and I don't know about Facebook
partner monetization I'm not sure about
that I need to look into that more I
know there are some people that actually
do that I already gave the bid on
building live events but obviously this
takes a tremendous amount of work to
manage your ticket sales do the banner
design the bio all that stuff you have
to manage a mailing list through a
company like MailChimp and you have to
try to not send too many emails to your
following only really profound and
important emails you have to host the
event and have a really strong
experience designed for not only the
guests that you're hosting as in like
Adam gazelle he was gonna be our guest
on Friday so they have to have a good
experience plus all of the actual guests
that are attending the event have to
have for the experience of listening the
fireside chat have to have a very
profound experience as well so then that
takes a little day and you have to build
out a team of volunteers or people that
you can actually pay even better with
the finances that you have because it's
really important to build together a
community of people like that and have
them show them the love through through
being able to support them financially
while they support you for helping your
efforts so live events are also
extremely complicated and very very fun
to do and it's important to do big live
events we've been obviously trying to
scale up our live events to only doing a
couple really large live events it like
we were talking about sports stadiums
every single year so you have to edit
video that's not live streamed which
actually takes a tremendous amount of
work to be able to do so that means
sitting behind a computer and a software
like Adobe Premiere and learning how to
go through the process of doing things
like these audio-video functionalities
so doing things like color correcting or
doing things like cutting out certain
segments that weren't that good or you
know doing things like adding adding
lower thirds adding adding effects so
that you can add imagery inside of it
you have to sometimes adjust audio
levels when one mic goes up or down it's
so much work to be in Premiere and to
learn how to do that and I only know
point zero zero one percent of premiere
I don't know how to do animations I
don't know how to do any of that stuff
yet and so again there's really good
editors again out there that's been
working on it for a long time so that's
another aspect to this you have to you
have to know how to cut short segments
from long-form convo so this is really
important because our show really
desperately needs to have our 60 minute
interviews cut into 1 minute 2 minute 3
minute segments and those cycle this
well throughout the internet and we are
behind on doing that because we are
still behind on getting the interviews
that we've recorded and did live stream
cut because I'm the only person that
does that and it's just it's a
tremendous amount of work and so we need
to as you up your financing as a
youtuber you can then hire other people
to help you with editing they hire other
people to help you with with actually
making what you're trying to build come
true at larger scales so we also have
here making 30 to 60 second short
profound videos so this means not the
long-form interview content and not
those interview segments cut up into
short clips but also actually making the
30 to 60 second videos that are more so
like you'll see them on our channel if
you go and look at welcome to simulation
on our channel or [ __ ] the rat race one
of those two videos you'll see kind of
how those are like fast chopped videos
and they're like diverse and there have
voiceovers the top
and so it's just a difference more like
film it's it's very interesting and that
you know that's a whole day process
that's a 10 a.m. for your roadmap and
your storyboard and then noon to 6 p.m.
is the shoot and then 6 p.m. to midnight
edit and publish so again and then you
have to actually publish they have to go
change the tags and the BIOS and
thumbnails and all that stuff I was
telling you about you do that the next
day as you push it out to Twitter
Instagram Facebook all the social
networks so it's crazy right how much
actual time it takes to do all this
stuff and this is good because you know
how when you go this is actually really
important really focus on this point so
you know how when you go to a restaurant
and you eat that all you do is sit at a
table and then someone else your food
the order food and someone else brings
you food one moment please and then all
you see is that the food has arrived at
the table you eat you pay and you leave
right but what happened is a very
complex system in the background
someone had to decide to make that place
a restaurant so there had to be a
building built there at some point by
humans there had to have been someone
that decided that they're gonna make a
restaurant they're gonna name it they're
gonna hire people they're gonna make a
menu they're gonna do that then they had
people there that means they have chefs
and waiters and waitresses and hosts and
people working in all these different
parts of the restaurant and then they
serve you that food so the it's
interesting because I usually see this
but someone that has worked at a
restaurant before will empathize more
with a restaurants processes and so you
might do something just super simple
like after you're done eating you might
stack your own dishes and then just pass
the dishes to the bus or when the bus
arrives so very simple things like that
can actually be very interesting so
that's why I'm bringing this up because
if you're actually watching this right
now you may not know all the nuance
behind what it takes to actually make
one of these videos and so I'm trying to
explain to you what actually goes on in
order for you to better understand what
the nuance of all the variables that go
into actually executing this and
building it out across all of it and you
know the bio of this video has a really
good breakdown of the like list of ten
things that are really important to
maintain while you here okay
and
other things that are really important
so you're learning how to do live
streams on the TriCaster that means you
know as you see here you see a you know
this is what a TriCaster looks like and
you see that the the you know right
there's just so much nuance of what's
actually happening on this on the screen
what I have to do in order to manage it
all and so so that's what we're using
we're using a TriCaster and then we are
zooming out for the next shot bringing
it back there it is so that you can see
from this angle again what's up and boom
and then so so again this like you have
to learn how to livestream on a
TriCaster that takes a lot of work you
have to learn the TriCaster software
itself that takes a lot of work the
TriCaster software's a bunch of
different things you can do you have to
learn how to use cameras that means you
have to learn how to actually use a
camera like focus it iris work on the
iris put it on a tripod know how to
manage the like an SDI connection in the
back and have that cable run of the
TriCaster an HDMI connection run there
you know like right now I'm using an NDI
input which is what's enabling me to
show you what's on my screen it's a
wireless input into the TriCaster and
then you know how to add assets video
and images and audio which you kind of
saw a little bit of is adding this stuff
you know this this screen right here
that I'm about to show you is we're
adding that's that's us adding content
to it that simulation logo and etc so
you switch between cameras fluidly is
extremely important having a fun
personality but also a strong mental
lattice and doing amas you know being
quirky like you guys you know you guys
know that I love being 40 you know I
like being different right
but I also love having a strong and
developed mental lattice that's
multidisciplinary so you can actually
relate with me on all different fronts
and I can relate with you on all those
different fronts so doing AMAs has been
really fun I learned so much from you
guys I already mentioned document don't
create this part super important
no two parties beer gardens Netflix
alcohol cannabis drugs increase for
people that are convenient for them but
they're not convenient for you so you
have to remember that people are always
trying to ask you to do things that are
convenient for them
oops convenient there we go
for them but interestingly enough that
is not actually most convenient for you
because you need to hustle and you need
to focus and you need to build on what
your creatively here to produce into the
world and so not every inquiry for your
times actually worth your time remember
that and it's also there's so many
people that are focused on too much
Netflix and chill and too many
conversations with people and too much
alcohol too much cannabis too many of
these of these escapist things but
they're not all xscape a-- straight you
can use cannabis medicinally and whatnot
for serious problems but and you can use
drugs like five amino DMT or or
ayahuasca or sell a siphon or LSD and
stuff and you can have really profound
consciousness expanding experiences but
not doing it super damn often so where
you can't actually creatively execute
but it's different for every single
person it's different for every person
but I'm saying you got to eat [ __ ] you
have to eat [ __ ] for ten years you have
to build the future the best way to
build the future is to eat [ __ ] for ten
years and just hustle from where near
twenty and tell when you're thirty and
creatively execute everything you want
into the world and set yourself up while
other people just are doing all these
things that they think are important for
their time now they'll notice that they
still have to work their ass off later
in their life meanwhile you will love
working your ass off later in your life
but you're gonna be doing what you love
because you're doing it as your own
creative output doing things like this
is this is this is very interesting an
eccentric sleep schedule low interest in
sex because it takes too much time a low
interest in long-term relationships
against too much time a low interest in
coffee meeting sloshed hangouts because
they're not usually that important for
you to do to just go meet with people
you have to apply the Pareto principle
to people networks and know who
the most important for you to meet and
so you need to focus on creating content
instead having an interest in a deep
interest in meditation nature bathing
and self work these are very important
things along the way cuz I'm talking
about eating [ __ ] and only hustling and
doing that but you have to also go to
muir woods go to the beach go out in
nature bathe for long periods of time
and self and practice working on
yourself through meditation and in we're
thinking and just to round it all off on
the way out you got to read a lot you
have to do a lot of knowledge synthesis
and you have to take a lot of notes you
have to build a strong mental lattice to
be one of the world's most Polymathic
tennis players and that's you know not
for every single person it's like that
but this is how I feel
and I think this is how when you develop
a business or a youtube channel you got
to do these things because people want
to be able to relate with you on a bunch
of different fronts they don't want to
just relate with you on just one front
usually and so if you know how to talk
about space like the International Space
Station orbits the earth every 90
minutes right and if you can know that
and if you can know that there are about
there's zero gravity in it they're about
six astronauts in it at a time if you
can know but that this is the Niagara
Falls and there's these gorgeous places
in the world that have these majestic
areas that that Earth has beautifully
blossomed on it the Amazon rainforest
and the diversity of the plants and
animals there you know if some people
like this type of stuff they like the
multidisciplinary this is what the world
looks like when it's all lit up at night
and from space and so you can tell that
there's certain patches like that right
there is the you know that rate that
right there's the Amazon and that's why
there's not light there right because
there's a big rain force there people
don't live there not that many do versus
the continental United States you can
see there's obviously a lot of people
living there especially on the East
Coast and whatnot and even towards the
Midwest so anyway knowing how to
synthesize knowledge like ancient
civilizations in big history and being
able to apply that into your daily life
is really important because there's a
lot of wisdom from the past that we can
apply moving forward to make us much
smarter and I take notes on everything I
highly recommend that you take notes on
every
thing to take a lot not everything
that's binary on a lot of the most
important things applying the Pareto
principle finding the most profound
things and taking notes to organize them
and keep them logged over time so again
you know building out a strong mental
lattice being from first principles so
so let's let's go do quick overview
building from first principles building
from first principles knowing your
elevator pitch applying things like the
Pareto principle to life knowing how to
find the best people networks and
knowledge networks understanding how to
play on social media and play in the
attention economy but not being sucked
too deep into it not letting it control
you knowing how to manage your finances
and manage other people that help you
build what you build doing things like
scaling you're scaling yourself up to
the next lily pads of execution so for
us that's the bigger sports stadiums
bigger sets as youtubers especially know
how to livestream know how to edit video
know the nuance of that know how to make
short videos know how to make long
videos and hustle grind don't be
distracted don't be distracted don't be
distracted don't be distracted actually
build focus on actually building to your
absolute best and that's it everyone
much love I want to just have a big
shout out to all the people that are
currently building the future on YouTube
on Facebook on these different social
platforms because it takes a long time
to build out a big following on these
different social platforms and and it's
a big part of the attention economy it's
a big part of disseminating your value
structures and your mental models of the
world and so I want to have a big shout
out to all of them and a big shout at
all you guys for tuning in huge thank
you for tuning in this has been the life
of running a youtube channel and it's
also a lot of this is the life of
running a business and a lot of this is
also the life of running a successful
creative ly driven and civilizational
maximisation life like how can you build
value into the world and go and do that
every single day of your life I love you
all huge thank you for tuning in much
love I will see you all soon
and definitely go and give us your
comments and your thoughts below I'd
love to hear from you I'd love to hear
from you and go and build the future
manifest your destiny into the world
everyone much love
[Music]